that's where he made his name last year
dark fate my man maddie d
is back see him is back as he slices
through and lays it up and in with the
left hand
ball accelerates
and is deflected here's van bleet
putting moves on reddick
[Applause]
[Applause]
he is a tough cover in this league that
go
no goaltending call 48-46
ciaco drains the three we're going
two-for-one there you might say whoa
what is he doing
there's lead by two lowry
to gasol here's pascal deep freeze
oh my goodness
is kendall walker a rare miss for him
here in the quarter
lead pass kyle pascal oh
what a connection 104
104. 33 from three-point range og
drive kick fans lead here's sayakam
attacking
oh now quick and slick was that move
snell and it doesn't go and surge with a
couple of boards here
lowry seattle running the floor
christian
wood a length of wood needs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sizing up wood spinning
[Applause]
spicy pig
from castle guard he went to the bullpen
and said i
would you're you're in a relief he's
waving everybody off he wants to go one
on one
[Applause]
he's on fire just can't get anything
right now
to drop two of ten in the quarter
milwaukee six of nine at this point
at the rim all kinds
into that milwaukee game it just seemed
that mark ran out of gas
like a lot of the other raptors he has
to take his shots
here's pascal spicy done your job
find the open man at that point exactly
keep the game simple and this is going
to help the raptors here
playing off of their d pascal in
transition
tied at 16. the aaron fox may have
shuffled his feet a little bit see him
with a
two-handed slam oh and matt thomas look
at this pass by fred
it is streaking pascal seattle
here's pascal driving on ingram top shot
and it goes
well they got him right in the middle of
the floor and beautiful shot over the
top together a
really good campaign it's easy to go
with the lakers but a whole new
level and see them just attacks ingram
off of the boundary
just opened up that time nobody's
shooting over 50
from three and a kid like ciaco close to
40 percent from
behind the arc major improvement pascal
catch and shoot oh pascal
pascal spinning what a beautiful move by
spicy p wow expensive rebounding
good pushes
oh spinning around on kuzma plus the
foul
look how deep 7-0 run look how deep he
got matt watch
looks how deep he gets in here right in
the restricted area and then over the
top
acousma but he gets right where he wants
to get to
in here that kick right foot in the
restricted area down a 5-0 run
see akam now attacking poked away in a
turnover
davis thrives denied by ciaco
powell denies bradley he can guard that
way
he's a 14 he's a one through four and
sometimes a five and a three
for sure 4
55 left back door cut james
doesn't go denied by pascal
davis grabs it dave is thriving
to the rim so raptor fans on their feet
sure look at that block
[Applause]
[Music]
13-2 run by toronto he wasn't able to
play last night in sacramento it was a
late scratch with back spasms
he helps them see yakum oh great
straight line driving transitioners down
by six and they've given up six second
chance points and just clean that up
the steal by ziakham great anticipation
driving set play sequence
to get you an open shot and fred van
fleet once again a big play
28 points give it up top pascal
slam junk that's what i'm talking about
right there
well maybe not skye in here he got it
sea
plus the foul there you go his clock is
down
skip pass pascal step back three
good it worked out just fine jacked us
away
they wanted it too and unable to corral
it
as he went up and it slipped off of his
fingertips
that was beautiful the denial by sea
you're going to have a great season
pamphlet turns the corner sends it now
pascal
and he banks it in just as he planned it
[Music]
oh yeah and you know what just like this
you got to run down the floor going yeah
shot clock down smothering defense taken
away
hand bleed here's powell running up
slams run for the rappers but all about
d
oh look at this three rappers collapse
on rozier
powell gets it out just tosses it up
there both teams are the foul to give
[Applause]
six second difference game fox shot
clock turnover
hollis jefferson seven seconds
five seconds pascal nobody's guarding
him and he just
banks it in trey young finds hunter
batted away scooped up three on one
norm with the reverse zia come on hunter
turner drives healthy comes
norm quickly exploding right to the rim
north finds pascal with the slab
in a foul annis
[Applause]
you see him you give it up and let
pascal
attack and he's so good at avoiding
[Applause]
simmons to the cutting harris denied
pascal
and you know where does it all start the
defensive end looks like an easy two for
harris and pascal
turns rises up doesn't go
simmons gets it back fires it
gazal to siako
pascal at the buzzer
[Applause]
in memphis with marcus all they had some
great runs together here's gasol
right now bay street with a two-handed
slam
men get shots up that's a good way to
take care of yourself to be ready to
play oh
pascal from timmins in an edo run
ciaco backing in on horford he'll spin
fading shot doesn't go batted out
scooped up kyle
finds c yakum and right
at the rim the slam dunk the saw
dangerous passer from the elbow finds
ciacom
and he punches it home like he didn't
want him to catch the ball
and so sometimes with that you're going
to give up the back door but he was just
like
i don't want you to catch the ball but
you got to have if you're going to deny
out there
pascal short and a long rebound
and taken down by brooklyn caruto
jack how about that here we go spicy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
all starting from the defense here's
seattle
turns fires at three good from
chatham
the pistons are the second best
three-point shooting team in the league
they've only shot two for 13 tonight
pascal drills it from essex you've done
a good job guarding the three and now
you're worried about your front court
clown trouble and spicy piecing
[Music]
[Applause]
here's seaakim backing in on paul here
comes a double
adam's there oh gee a wide open three
and a good side pascal attacking
ferguson
now pulls it back out i'm going to clear
out let him go to work
spin dribble what a sweet move
spicy pee oh my goodness look at ciaco
single coverage a little spicy peep spin
get some big sponsor and then yeah when
we get into the playoffs
you know get everybody going here's
pascal
26 points perfect nine for nine his last
five games against toronto
he has been terrific shooting 56 percent
up top
how about that now is the time when as
you're healthy
you've got your seven or eight guys
you're gonna mix and match and try to do
some different things
oh boy look at that we'll sometimes
start and sometimes come off the pec
bench depending on match-up or is the
team big
well we know what the song can do he can
pass it a beautiful assist to ciaco
defensive player of the year he's always
had
vision and touch knows how to play
attacking aldrich
in the paint now sends it og they'll
whip it around
and send it back to pascal who drains it
and he's got 18
and an 8-0 run just fired a bullet to
him look at this pass
right there quick a lot of time for
pascal to line it up and shoot it
sets the screen fred in the paint on a
kick out
and the corner three is good and the
most points in a quarter for a raptor
forbes a deep three short van fleet with
it
into the front court sprinting ahead
pascal
slam dunk running the floor last
possession for the raptors how about
that pass from fred
so is pascal headed to the bucket fred
had that ball up there and waiting for
him
beautifully placed pass both meetings so
they hold the tiebreaker as we head to
that february second date when the
all-star
coach the other all-star approach will
be announced seattle
underneath the right to the power game
good flash
across the lane and ciaco eastern
conference player of the week
gasol helped breadband bleed out big
time on that matchup oh boy what a cut
lowry right to the rim
big reason why they're there is number
seven in white kyle
seacombe with a shot clock down step
back three
rack it up like the virginia squires and
the kentucky colonels
stole it away here's jeff tego
look at some of that the raptors in for
ogn inoby he finished the game last
night finished strong and there's
powell with a slam dunk 10 points three
or four from three
pascal guarded by morris three
good back to back threes
screamed by lowry in that action pascal
backing in on thaddeus young
spinning shot up good oh man what a
big-time play they know the postseason
what's going to happen with things kind
of bog down a little
bit here it is right here look at this
this is a tough play
good shot contest
comes pascal clocked down nice pass
davis corner got it from brockville okay
that was
outstanding pascal siacome
pascal looks at the shot clock
over mcdermott got it
big bucket the toronto raptors average
right around three
less which sends them down to 17th in
the nba
in field goal attempts pascal a blocking
foul
count it he'll go to the line off the
bat
everybody's pushing trying to get it
going pascal ciaco
great job in transition getting out
using his body
against hernan gomez beasley gets hung
up on a screen house jefferson turns the
corner
here's ciaco on the inside alice
jefferson
working underneath
batted away by hollis jefferson scooped
up by pascal
and great patience soaring through
anthony towns it's stolen away see
hacker now gets it to kyle
lowry attacking finds og again
and another stop can they get it going
here in transition
pascal to the rim plus the foul there
you go
sergio bacca with the big defensive play
get that damage out of here
siakim off to the races
bucket bucket timeout
good look good the three is good does
that provide life
just made a tough one does that get the
raptors going
they're down 10 the nets 19 and 9 when
they lead after three
can the raptors make it 10 losses for
the nets when they lead
here's ciaco coming across puts the
speed on
and pete leonard off the dribble
[Applause]
pascal by baines and a pullback the
three is
good makes it to holliday the
three-pointer doesn't go
now you know what i'm saying from the
toronto raptors and obviously this
brief picture the three is good
pascal seacom from owen sound
that all-star break that understands
what's coming up
and they are getting ready 744 on the
clock here in the first
quarter here's pascal finds serge
gathers
banks it in and ibaka has nine points
in his 23rd start and see akam comes
down with it his fourth rebound
pascal now in the paint drive and a
blocking foul
on a martin count it
check this out crossover right here
coming in and
the defender never had position getting
underneath pascal
ozzie's taking a step right here good
job by
get that ball before get the defense on
your heel start moving with the pass and
maybe you'll play like this
oh the end over the shoulder
the head charlotte on the inside
rafters are 8 to 38 from
three-point range pascal with 24 now
that's a game hot
and there's craig denied by pascal
he's running the floor lead past davis
davis up top
sea akkam with a slam dunk that's a
great block right here by pascal siacome
and getting out and running nice pass
from terence davis and
again here's your one concern you've got
a couple of guys right now
norm powell we're off to a good start
the other night against golden state but
then they stopped playing hard
and that's been an issue with this team
part of that is youth c
akam with a slam dunk let's see that
move maddie decisive they're like eight
and a chance to react
you see he's a step behind beat him off
the dribble and pascal's got that nice
step
and able to coming in and being
aggressive but also defense he's been
extremely pesky
on rapper guards here's carter oh ciaco
with the denial on the help
side loose ball foul check this out
carter goes up goes strong and
stack him sends it out big time
and kyle lowry he took a he took a dive
into the front
row right there matt mccall he started
the game did not start the second half
to help d
comes here comes ciaco oh gee back up
top whoa
oh oh pascal
wow oh gee oh my
whoa add another thing to norma's game
matt a playmaker
nice job of just dropping that ball off
to bach and here the defense doing it
again
here's pascal and he lays it up and
through
the fox fox in the air and a turnover
baca lowry powell numbers up top
pascal you could see that play coming
as soon as kyle got rid of the ball as
soon as kyle gets rid of it
you know what's going to happen here
because pascal is running
it up there nicely and sacramento
struggling coming on the shot clock norm
up top here's pascal
see yakum
[Applause]
his shot setting his teammates up and
you know pascal siacombe this is a
tough tough shot unbelievable but drains
it
look at this look at all that pressure
but you know what he did he did a great
job just
to really stun on ciaco maybe send a
defender at him
to hopefully get the ball up early tough
shot but he knocked it down right there
took the game over and willed his team
to victory
the deep three and it goes isn't it
amazing when guys have a good game
against a team player